accueillant Vladimir Poutine 38e
rencontre entre les deux hommes c'était
il y a un mois
l'occasion de vanter une amitié sans
limite et une coopération sans interdit
entre les deux pays depuis il y a eu
l'invasion russe que la Chine ne
condamne pas et des sanctions
économiques sans précédent contre la
Russie venant de toutes parts sauf de
Pékin nous sommes fermement opposés aux
sanctions alors si jimping va-t-il voler
au secours économiquement de Vladimir
Poutine tout un symbole au premier jour
de la guerre les Chinois ont levé les
restrictions à l'importation de blé
russe céréales matières premières et
essentiellement hydrocarbures la Chine
en redemande et ça tombe bien Moscou en
a revendre les deux pays ont signé un
accord de construction d'un second
gazoduc reliant la Russie à la Chine si
l'eau Sibérie le premier pipeline le
voici il est entré en service en 2019
lançait juste après l'invasion de la
Crimée entre les deux voisins les
affaires continuent la preuve aussi par
le chocolat sur ce site officiel de
produits russes vendu en Chine tout est
aujourd'hui en rupture de
aujourd'hui je suis très contente j'ai
reçu mes commandes regardez tout ça ce
sont des produits russes
dans ce contexte international compliqué
nous voyons que nous pouvons compter sur
notre vieil ami chinois la Chine peut
atténuer la douleur infligée par les
sanctions mais avec prudence depuis
l'exclusion par exemple du système Swift
des banques russes les banques chinoises
n'ont pas volé à leur secours je
déséquilibriste de Pékin qui ne voit pas
d'un mauvais œil cette nouvelle
dépendance de Moscou à son égard mais
qui ne veut pas non plus sacrifier sa
relation avec les États-Unis et l'Union
européenne ses principaux partenaires
économiques